[Music]
in ursula k le guin's third earth sea
novel the farthest shore we see once
again ged or sparrowhawk now as the
archmage as one of the
main characters he was the primary
character in a wizard of earthsea and he
was the second most important character
in the tombs of ottawa but now we get
introduced to another main character a
young man who's not much older than ged
was
in a wizard of earthsea in the early
parts rn who is a
noble person he's descended from this
great hero
morad through this this lineage uh the
princes of enlarge and his father has
sent him on a mission and with a certain
we could say scope to it that is going
to prove very important he gets to meet
ged as the arc mage as sparrowhawk
and he's going to pledge a commitment to
him
that will run throughout the entire
novel and prove to be an absolutely
central point and it's going to get
re-understood
tested
modified and found to
hold true so at the very beginning
we find him talking with
ged and explaining the the problem the
crisis as they're going to discern that
they're only seeing the fringe edges of
and we we get this nice description
alan and lord looked up to his father
and he was his father's son no man just
talking about
sparrowhawk now had ever looked at him
thus not as aaron prince of enlar son of
the ruling prince but as aaron
alone ged looks at him as a person
he did not like to think he feared the
arc mage's gaze but he could not meet it
it seemed to enlarge the world yet again
around him
and now not only enlarged his
insignificance but he himself so that in
the eyes of the archmage he was only a
small figure very small in a vast scene
of secret lands over which hung darkness
so
the encounter with get or sparrowhawk is
something that
induces in him a sense of perspective
and he responds to it
spontaneously
here's what he says
um
he he sat picking at the vivid moss that
grew in the cracks of the marble
flagstones
presently he said hearing his voice
which had deepened only in the last
couple of years sound thin and husky
i shall do as you bid me
gad says your duty is to your father
not to me
and then aaron
gets up and kneels down formally on both
knees my lord he said stammering let me
serve you his self-assurance was gone
his face was flushed his voice
shook
he draws his sword out and offers the
hill to the ark mage as a liege man to
his prince the archmage did not put out
his hand to touch the sword hill he
looked at it and at aaron and said that
is yours not mine and you are no man's
servant and then aaron says
my father said i might stay on rock
until i learned what this evil is and
maybe some mastery i i have no skill
i don't think i have any power but there
are mages among my forefathers if i
might in some way learn to be of use to
you and the archmage says before your
ancestors were mages they were kings
this is going to be a very important
point
then he tells them
i thank you for your offer of service
though i do not accept it now yet i may
when we have taken counsel on these
matters the offer of a generous spirit
is not one to refuse
lightly nor is the sword of the son of
morad to be lightly turned aside
so god is telling this boy
who has
spontaneously without thinking about it
but in a right way
pledged his feel to your loyalty to get
i may take you up on that and there'd be
good reasons for me to do that but
remember
your job is not to be a sorcerer your
job is not to be a mage your job is to
engage in some sort of rulership and
that ultimately
is where
the young prince the young prince ling
is
headed a little bit later there's a
conference
between all of the the great masters of
rogue and they're unable to attain
consensus and then ged invites aaron to
breakfast with them a big honor and
then ged decides that he's going to
to leave
and seek out the trouble
so he says
i'm going to take
rn as a companion if he'll do it
therefore i ask aaron will you come with
me aaron says yes my lord and the
changer says the prince your father
surely would not let you go into this
peril
and
he says the lad is young and not trained
in wizardry and sparrowhawk says i've
got enough spells what would your father
say and aaron says he would let me go
the summoner says how can you know that
and aaron says
well when my father sent me
here he said to me i fear a dark time is
coming on the world a time of danger
so i send you rather than any other
messenger for you can judge
whether we should ask the help of the
isle of the wise in this matter or
offer the help of enlarge to them so if
i am needed therefore i am here and he's
given what we call discretion the
capacity to make his own
judgment about the situation he's not
just following orders and so he
gives his loyalty to get who says okay
i'll take it now we're on a mission
and that is really what the rest of the
book is about one of the key incidents
is
when they are in horde town
and with the
at one time mage now addict and whatever
he is here
and they are uh attacked by by robbers
aaron is going to run away
and the way that it's originally
described you know he's he's taking off
and running away and only later on do we
find out what his motivation
was
so
sparrowhawk
says you know
why why did you run away at that time uh
actually uh
before that aaron says i failed my guard
and he said and get says not by falling
asleep and he says no i was you were
ahead of me i saw you and so they crept
in and tapped us on the head like lambs
at the shambles took gold good clothes
and the saleable slave and left it was
you they were after lad you'd fetch the
price of a farm in amron market they
didn't tap me hard enough i woke up i
did give them a run i spilt their loot
all over the street before they cornered
me and so sparrowhack says why did you
run and he says to get them away from
you
the surprise in sparrowhawk's voice
suddenly struck aaron's pride and he
added fiercely i thought it was you they
were after i thought they might kill you
i grabbed their bags so they'd follow me
and shouted and ran and they did follow
me and sparrowhawk says well of course
they did they were after you you were
the prize so interestingly of course ged
saves aaron right but aaron in a certain
sense thinks that he's saving
ged and he puts himself in peril
in doing so
aaron doesn't just simply accept
everything docile he actually will speak
up when he thinks that ged is making the
wrong decisions for example when he is
taking uh soaply the insane
touched
damaged old dyer of uh uh
the the the silks
and he says um why are you taking this
guy
uh and god says as a guide a guide to
more madness to death by drowning or a
knife in the back to death but
by what road i do not know
aaron spoke with heat and though
sparrowhawk answered quietly there was
something of a fierce note in his voice
and aaron says this
i would not quarrel with you my lord
but this this is beyond reason and god
says
you're right
it is beyond all reason we go where
reason will not take us will you come
or will you not
and aaron says i said i would come with
you and serve you i do not break my
word that is well the mage said grimly
and made as if to turn away then he
faced aaron and he tells him this
i need you aaron and you need me for i
will tell you now that i believe this
way we go is
yours to follow
not out of obedience or loyalty to me
but because it was yours to follow
before you ever saw me before you ever
set foot in rock before you sailed from
enlarge you cannot turn back from it so
he's saying
i accept your loyalty i accept your
fealty but realize that you are actually
following your destiny as well
and a little bit later on you know aaron
goes through what we could call a crisis
of faith and
get gets wounded they wind up on the
great rafts of the children of the open
sea
and then they have a heart to heart and
aaron
confesses to god that he thinks that he
has failed him and betrayed him he says
i failed you i will fail you again and
fail myself i have not strength enough
and god says to him you have strength
enough
the mage's voice was tender but beneath
tenderness was the same hardness that
had risen in the depths of aaron's own
shame and mocked him
what you will what you love you will
love what you undertake you will
complete you are a fulfiller of hope you
are to be relied upon
but 17 years give little armor against
despair
and
he tells them
continuing on
i will not take the council of despair
you are in
are my guide you and your innocence and
your courage and your unwisdom and your
loyalty you are my guide the child i
send before me into the dark it is your
fear your pain i follow you've thought
me harsh to you aaron but you never knew
how harsh i use your love as a man burns
a candle burns it away to light his
steps and we must go on we must go on we
must go all the way we must come to the
place where the sea runs dry and joy
runs out the place to which your mortal
terror draws you and he says aaron says
but what if i should fail again and
betray you and ged says i will trust you
son of morad
on
celador that is indeed
what they do they go into the dry land
the realm of the dead which has now
become connected in ways it should not
be with the land of the living and ged
gives him an option he says to him
listen we are now going to go and face
the enemy
head on
he says you know where we're going to go
into the dark land i among them
and and
are and says i have seen them now i will
go with you
god says is it faith in me that moves
you you may trust my love but i do i do
not trust my strength
i think i've met my match
i will go with you
but if i am defeated or my power my life
is spent i cannot guide you back you
cannot return alone
and aryn says i will return with you.
god says
you enter your manhood at the gate of
death
and
notice what's going on here
the way that they understand it is
anybody but a mage going into the land
of the dead can't get out on their own
even some mages can't we find the
summoner wandering around there unable
to get out on his own before ged gives
him some advice
aaron says i will die for you i will go
into the dry land living
and be stuck there if you should happen
to die but you won't die because
we will get out together and that turns
out to be
what actually happens after they deal
with cobb
after ged pours out all of his
power and nearly all of his life
it's aaron who saves him
we read there was no more light on god's
youth staffer in his faith face when
aaron came to him he caught at the young
man's arm to hold himself
upright
he said it is done it is all gone gad
was like one bewildered or exhausted he
followed aaron back down the river
course stumbling along slowly with
difficulty
and
aaron is leading them through the the
mountains of of pain
he's saying we must go on my lord
eventually he has to
carry god
get off and stumbled or missed his
footing and weariness his breath came
harder and harder when his hands came
hard against the rocks he gasped in pain
to hear him cry out
wrung aaron's heart he tried to keep him
from falling but often the way was too
narrow for them to go abreast or aaron
had to go in front to seek out footing
at last on a high slope that ran up to
the stars gad slipped and fell forward
and did not get up my lord aaron said
kneeling by him and then spoke his name
ged
he did not move her answer
aaron lifted him in his arms and carried
him up that high slope at the end of it
there was level ground for some way
ahead aaron laid his burden down and
dropped down beside him exhausted and in
pain past hope
endurance may outlast hope he crawled
forward when he was able to do doggedly
he looked over the edge of darkness he
turned back to the dark he went back he
lifted get up as best as he could and
struggled forward with him till he could
not go any far farther there all things
ceased to be thirst and pain and the
dark and sun's light and the sound of
the breaking sea
aaron
manages to get ged out of the land of
the dead out of the dry land
back onto the shores of celador
where the oldest dragon
in existence
finds them and then takes them
on their journey back
home
so aaron fulfills his commitment he goes
down with ged
into the land of the dead and brings him
back out of it faces the enemy together
the commitment that he made he follows
through on
you